e
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 552 and here from the prime
sponsor representa new welcome to the
Commerce Committee thank you very much
Mr chairman and thank you me members of
the committee I'm here this morning to
introduce House Bill 552 my name is
representative James Nome and I
represent the towns of bow and
hopkington I filed this bill at the
request of constituents to make a small
change to the state retire insurance
plan eligibility that will yield several
important benefits currently the state
retire insurance plan allows coverage
for 19 to 25y old children if they are
full-time students this bill seeks the
simple change of removing the full-time
student requirement to allow coverage of
all children within this age group this
change brings the retiree plan in
alignment with current state employee
plans and other ACA plans importantly
this change will not cost New Hampshire
taxpayers a single penny all premiums
will be paid by the retiree and not the
state additionally 19 to 25 year olds
tend to be healthier and therefore cost
less to ensure which means that adding
these healthier individuals to the
insurance pool Joyce Pitman the director
of risk and benefits lays out this out
well in her testimony which I submitted
which I passed around this
morning in fact this change May decrease
State costs because the department of
administrative Services won't have to
verify eligibility based on uh being a
student just age which is easier to
track and changes with 100%
predictability two other potential
benefits albeit un Quan unquantifiable
are that this benefit enhancement could
Aid in hiring essential state employees
or encourage decisions to retire
earlier by way of History this bill was
introduced last year it received an 110
vote in house executive departments and
administration committee and a five vote
commit 5 zero committee vote in the
other body before a non- gerine
amendment was attached and killed it on
the table I hope you view this bill
favorably and vote ought to pass thank
questions okay seeing none uh I would
only say that you know you you do good
when you have uh your two co-sponsors or
former members of this
committee it's better to be lucky than
good thank you very
much okay uh is anybody else interested
in testifying I would I forgot my
gavl do you have time Mr
uh to the next one I did schedule a
whole half hour on this I don't know
what I don't know what I was
thinking I guess I didn't I didn't read
the bill when I scheduled it I was not
thinking straight but I do have to I do
have homework I have to do I have to get
ready for next
week so did you want to speak Dave
yeah all right you will put a card in
later I will will put a card in Mr chair
thank you thank you very much um and uh
and thanks for indulging representative
Newsome uh this is his first bill
introduction so so I can think of no
better committee for a uh for a first uh
first term uh legislator to you know cut
their teeth but here in the Commerce
Committee so is that enough sucking
right well the the problem is is that
yeah and I'm represent pus chair
pus I'm the only person in the room who
remembers when we did if full-time
students when we removed it for
insurance right right was and so so I
don't need to ask any questions because
I know the whole history around that
limitation right no and and all I wanted
to point out for um um for the members
of the committee is that um the the
state retiree health insurance plan is
is um captured in statute so it's
defined in statute uh in um
where we um RSA
21i uh and and so it removes just the
words if full-time student so it removes
that limitation from from the statute
and um and according to um uh director
pitman's testimony it affects very very
few um retirees and um and as her
testimony goes on it uh it has no cost
to the to the state and As Nice benefit
so uh
thank you very much we're all good all
right good I'll get you a card thank you
all right having no more cards we'll
e
okay we'll open up the public hearing
and House
Bill
678 or 648 oh 648 648 why my contacts
are fuzzy
648 and here from the prime sponsor
representative Damon good morning
so good morning again chairman hunt
committee members colleagues and public
that might be watching I am
representative hope Damon Sullivan
District 8 the lovely towns of aworth
Langdon lemster Goan Washington lemster
Springfield Sunapee my hometown mccroy
in the City of Claremont I serve on the
education funding committee where I am
trying to lower our property
taxes I spend a rewarding 42-year career
as a dietitian and diabetes educator
initially I was in hospital and
long-term care positions then 35 years
in my own private practice I retired in
December of
22 I'm here today to introduce HB 648
which seeks to require commercial
insurance coverage for glucose
monitoring devices and supplies for
people with diabetes glucose another
name for blood sugar glucose monitoring
is essential to diabetes management and
safety I'm going to give you a quick
background on Diabetes because I don't
know how much you all know um and then
explain the merits of this proposed
legislation diabetes is serious costly
common treatable and bipartisan
condition there is no cure at this time
98300 or so New Hampshire residents have
been diagnosed with diabetes that's
about 9% of our adult population another
29,000 have undiagnosed diabetes and
about 88,200 of those folks with
undiagnosed diabetes are diagnosed
annually so we are increasingly
recognizing people's status with
diabetes and there is a whopping 350,000
New Hampshire people about 30% of our
population that have a condition called
pre-diabetes that's when your blood
sugar level is higher than normal but
not yet at the diagnosis level
pre-diabetes is likely to become
diabetes if it's not recognized and
addressed in uh Medical
Care medical expenses for people with
diabetes are about two and a half times
what people without diabetes have that's
data from American Diabetes
Association so what is it it's a chronic
illness in which the pancreas does not
produce enough insulin or the insulin
that is produced does not work
adequately because of this untreated or
inadequately managed diabetes results in
high blood sugars and that can lead to
very serious
complications in addition to not feeling
very well when your blood sugar is high
for many people with diabetes but not
all some people don't really even notice
that their blood sugar is high it can
lead to heart disease kidney failure
painful neuropathy which can also affect
your Mobility vision loss and blindness
are the most common complications of
diabetes pretty sure nobody here wants
any of those things for us or our
constituents with today's knowledge and
treatment options complications are
largely preventable at least in people
diagnosed now not so much in people
who've had diabetes a long time and may
already have some damage or they can at
least be delayed and be less severe so
there's really a lot that we can do to
help people with
diabetes in order for diabetes to
adequately be managed the patient needs
to have ongoing knowledge of their blood
sugar so that they can make healthy
treatment and lifestyle decisions
multiple times a day
there's some variance in the types of
diabetes and the way they're treated and
the relevance to this bill type 1
diabetes requires the patient to take
external insulin either by injections or
by a pump it affects about 10% of people
with diabetes glucose monitoring devices
and supplies are largely already covered
by insurers for type 1 diabetes so that
is not included in this build uh there's
not a
need people with type two two diabetes
have insulin resistance which means that
their bodies don't utilize insulin
effectively this is the most common type
of Diabetes almost 90% of patients with
diabetes have type 2 it's strongly
hereditary it is treated with diet
exercise and medications the medications
may or may not include insulin depending
on the patient's status and needs and
then the third type that I'll mention is
gational diabetes which is diabetes Di
AG noosed during
pregnancy if not treated it results in
larg babies more difficult deliveries
increased risk to both mother and child
and you'll hear a bit more about that
from one of my
colleagues this bill addresses glucose
monitoring for people with type two or
gestational
diabetes type 2 diabetes is a
progressive disease when first diagnosed
many people with type two can keep their
blood glucose at a healthy level with a
combination of meal planning nutrition
knowledge physical activity and taking
oral medication pills of which there are
a number of different options that work
in different ways but over time the body
gradually produces less and less of its
own insulin and uses it less and less
well or less and less effectively and
eventually lifestyle efforts and oral
medication may not be enough to keep
blood glucose levels in a healthy range
and at that point in the past patients
were prescribed insulin because that
used to be the only option when the oral
medications and lifestyle measures
didn't work now we have a whole toolbox
of a variety of different kinds of
medication um Beyond pills injectables
that are daily or weekly that are
helpful in managing blood
sugars understanding the realities of
diabetes is crucial for effec management
and a healthier life managing diabetes
isn't just about taking medication it's
about maintaining a balanced lifestyle
and making informed daily
choices there are at least 40 variables
that affect blood
glucose I decided not to copy this page
for all of you but I would be happy to
share it there's just so many pieces of
paper for reps right but among these in
addition to the obvious the many
different parts of nutrition like
carbohydrate quantity carbohydrate type
fat both quantity and type protein
caffeine alcohol the timing of eating
hydration or lack thereof your personal
microbiome we're actually learning more
and more that what happens in the gut
affects blood sugars and the way that we
manage um
medications so that's one category of
factors that affect blood glucose then
medication including what the medication
is what the dose is what the timing is
whether there's interaction c s if the
patient needs steroid treatment for some
other condition that is almost certain
to aggravate blood sugar control not
always in a completely predictable way
um people who might be taking nasin
which is vitamin B3 which is sometimes
recommended for the neuropathy
complication but unfortunately nasin
also causes increased blood sugar so
it's a bit of a catch
22 I won't detail all of these but
activity also makes a big difference
essentially exercise lowers blood
sugar while you're exercising and there
can also be a post exercise effect hours
later that you can have an unexpected
decrease in blood sugar from the healthy
good exercise you did earlier in the day
the intensity the duration of the
exercise the relationship of when it
happens relative to when you ate and
then a
um dozen and a half list of biological
variables including sleep
stress um Scar Tissue where insulin
might be inserted allergies menstruation
puberty celiac disease smoking it
literally goes on and on not every
person with diabetes has issues with all
of these factors that affect blood
glucose but the point really is to say
there are so many variables it is
different for every patient and it is
not
consistent Within one patient all of the
time you simply can't know how your
blood sugar is doing except by testing
it you cannot consistently and reliably
feel a common risk without adequate
glucose monitoring is
Hypoglycemia hypoglycemia is profoundly
low blood sugar that impairs cognition
and if it's not treated it will
ultimately cause loss of consciousness
hypo can occur slowly or
rapidly there can be symptoms that alert
you that it's happening but not
necessarily the longer someone has had
diabetes and the more episodes of low
blood sugar that they have experienced
the more likely that they will have what
we call hypoglycemia unawareness so
their blood sugar is dropping and they
have no perception that that is
happening so they're not going to do
anything about treating it because
they're not aware there's anything to
the um anecdote that I will share about
that because it will forever stay in my
mind I had a patient who was a
logger he was in his 50s he was a hearty
guy he was trying to pay decent
attention to taking care of his diabetes
he lost some weight you know he's trying
to do a reasonably good
job he was however not very committed to
blood sugar monitoring at the time the
only approach to blood sugar monitoring
was what we call finger stick you've
probably seen this advertised on TV you
poke your finger you get a teeny tiny
drop blood it goes on a test strip
reacts with a a chemical in the strip
and gets read by a little device that's
half the size of your cell phone but you
have to do that periodically he was not
committed to doing that he experienced
low blood sugar multiple times while he
was operating a
chainsaw he was a really hard worker and
he would push himself to complete the
tasks at hand he would not be aware of
going low until he would
collapse one day he came into my office
and he said well I threw the saw aside
like I always do when I started to fall
down and it hit my
boot good thing he was wearing steel
toed boots and it just scarred his boot
because he would have lost all or part
of his foot from hypoglycemia on
awareness that he didn't know he was
going low until he started to literally
crash um
it wasn't too long after that that
continuous glucose monitors became more
available which is largely what we're
going to speak about in this bill and
once he had a continuous glucose monitor
they will alert
you just like a cellphone alert that
your blood sugar is dropping and they
will communicate how rapidly is it
dropping gradually or
abruptly he thought I was God because I
got him a
CGM I most definitely am not God um um
but it really was phenomenal to see the
difference in his ability to make good
decisions about his
care um let's see I have actually
already said that oh in the past when
lifestyle and pills were not adequate to
manage a patient's blood sugar as I
noted the only further treatment option
used to be insulin insulin can very
effectively control blood sugar but it
also makes it harder for people to
control their weight which is a very
very common concern in type 2 diabetes
not all but most people with type two
diabetes are overweight when they're
diagnosed overweight increases the risk
of diabetes complications especially
heart disease so now we have wonderful
medications that can replace insulin
treatment in many people with type 2
diabetes managing blood sugar as well or
better than insulin and actually helping
with Weight Control these are the same
meds we're hearing a lot about that
people are using and are very interested
in for weight control independent
diabetes and many of them are injectable
meds patients taking these meds patients
who have diabetes do have risk of
hypoglycemia from them in the similar
way as with insulin and therefore need
to monitor their blood sugars to be
safe one of the other situations where
hypoglycemia becomes very serious is
when you're driving if you have low
blood sugar profound low blood sugar
while you're driving you'll drive like
you have DWI and in fact there are
multiple documented cases is over many
many years of people being stopped for
erratic driving or having been in an
accident and the law enforcement and
First Responders think they're impaired
by alcohol and they may have had nothing
at all to drink it's that their blood
sugar is
low we noted the traditional way to
check blood sugar with a finger stick or
excuse me the Contemporary and very
useful alternative continuous glucose
monitoring is wearing a sensor they're
very small about the size of a quarter
often worn on your shoulder and it
inserts into the skin just into the
subcutaneous tissue right underneath the
skin and they're worn for 7 to 14 days
and then you have to replace the
sensor they assess your blood sugar
status all the time
247 and the information can either be
received simply by taking your phone and
just swipe like that and look at it and
it'll tell you what's your blood sugar
right this minute um or it can go to an
app and be communicated also to other
people so like a spouse might be helpful
in monitoring somebody's blood sugar if
they want them to and they could receive
well and we spoke about them alerting
the patient when your uh glucose is
dropping or Rising very significantly
telling excuse me
how quickly the change is happening
which is very beneficial for preventing
hypoglycemia it's also very beneficial
for being able to make plans let's say
you're in committee and there's only one
more build to here but you're running
late the chair decides we're not
breaking for lunch yet if you're a
person with diabetes and you don't know
what your blood sugar is that might not
be okay because you may be dropping and
you may need to
eat um one of my colleagues excuse me is
going to speak more about gestational
diabetes I'm just going to note that the
significance of gational diabetes of
cgms and gational diabetes is largely
because of the concise time frame of
that condition pregnancy obviously ends
most gational diabetes is diagnosed at
six or seven months of pregnancy so you
have a very short time frame for that
patient to get informed about how to
take care of the blood sugar for
themselves and The Unborn so there's an
urgency to having that information in an
efficient and timely
manner continuous glucose monitoring
saves lives it has great return on
investment and we need to be covered by
insurers so that patients can access it
routinely for all type two people and
for all people with gational
diabetes thank you very much for your
time I am happy to try to answer
questions um and then have support from
folks behind
me
okay uh excuse me represent are you are
yeah well generally we don't but since
you're not
testifying I know but generally you're
you're not supposed to be asking
question normally you turn to someone
next to you and have them ask the
question then that's not a good question
but I will give you I'll let you off
this one time you get one question
better make it
good thank you Mr
chair so here's my question thank you is
I can't see over the this thing thank
you uh when we when last
when when last we spoke of this which
was admittedly quite a while ago uh we
were provided by the insurance
department a pretty
detailed uh analysis is of where the
costs were regarding this C the
CGM and we worked out the numbers and
figured out how much it would cost per
patient or per
prescriber and said okay that's within a
realm of reasonableness and so it looked
it looked good but there's two two
questions I have for you one is on page
two line one and two it said Pro it says
cover coverage under this paragraph
shall be provided without regard to the
form of treatment I'd like you to say
something without the prescribed form or
you know something to make it sound like
it's medical it's not somebody just
going and having a whim is that yes um
thank you for the question I think it
would be absolutely fine to amend the
bill to include the word prescribed in
line one on page two that is in fact
what we mean the point of that statement
is that when cgms first came out and in
some insurance coverage still
today they were
only covered for people who were using
insulin who were needing insulin so this
newer but by no means brand new
generation of meds that are not insulin
are very helpful for blood sugar control
and weight
management if we don't specify that we
want cgms ailable to people with other
forms of treatment besides insulin it
might get limited to just insulin which
wouldn't be very helpful frankly it
would be better follow on to that so
prescribe would be great just okay let
me let me just try you're gonna okay let
me try Okay so I'm on met Foreman now
because I I hit
6.5 and I assume which by changing the
form of regardless the form of treatment
is you want to allow me to be able to
take advantage of this mandate that is
correct
that okay may I explain I'm a quick
study yes go first of all kudos to you
for respecting your condition and taking
good care of it it really makes such a
difference it because otherwise I was
going to have to stop you know she
wanted me on keto bread and and all this
other stuff that I just no that was not
going to work for me so if I was still
in practice I'd give you by card ser but
not
um the more information in general that
people have about their blood sugar
status the more likely that they make
smart decisions about how to take care
of it so a quick for instance I remember
this patient with type two diabetes also
on met
Foreman
um she got a trial CGM when there was a
loner program from one of the companies
for Just Two Weeks literally was blown
away by her increased
understanding of the different impact of
portion
size that she concluded she could eat
ice cream after dinner every night if
she ate a half cup she could manage her
blood sugar well and if she ate what she
had previously been eating which was a
good bit more it's not surprising that
the quantity would make the blood sugar
higher but the quantitative data of it
made it this much higher made it
unacceptable to her to continue doing
that so cgms are value for people
regardless of form of
treatment okay so here comes the
question that I really want to
ask um 6.5 means i' you I was 6.4
marginal you know so I'm now in and out
of A1C okay now not withstanding that
when it came to blood sugars they they
moved the goalpost back when it was 130
and then they went to 100 okay and at
that point yes I stared to take those
glucose test kits um but uh the my
insurance company wouldn't cover it uh
because um I it wasn't it was the A1C I
had to get my A1C number up high enough
to to do it the glucose number so here's
my real my question is is that in terms
of where is the proper threshold here
for these to have us mandate this more
expensive device testing now you might
argue I don't know that given that the
cost of these test kits it's it it was
like know over the counter it's $80 for
like 50 of them okay and and that was
pretty consistent Walmart and and
Hanford um it uh I did find $40 at
Amazon ironically um however so but
insurance companies cover it if you have
if you're up a certain
level my question question is I was I
was the whole all of this is all driven
by my doing a uh you know uh a fasting
test at my doctor's okay so in my mind
that the time for me to be taking this
test is in the morning before I eat or
drink or do anything so in my mind this
thing that you're talking about this
monitor which is monitoring all day long
okay is really not addressing what my
original diagnosis was based upon which
was a fasting test okay so the question
is and and you're hit it right on the
thing is you know regard the form of
treatment it's at what level of diabetes
of type two diabetes you
have what is it the before we really you
really need to have this monitoring
that's monitoring you 247 seven rather
than just you know taking your blood in
you know uh once a morning if you were
going to be that crazy about doing it
thank you for the
question just a quick background because
I didn't mention A1C in my remarks and
so in case any of the folks listening
are not familiar with that A1C is a
blood test that measures average BL
average blood glucose over about a
two-month period of time it's not
actually an average but for Simplicity
and explaining it we say that it's a
Marvel right um and so it is one of the
measures of whether diabetes is well
controlled people who don't have
diabetes have an A1C between 4.8 and
5.7 and it can go up I think the highest
one I ever saw was 21 which was pretty
awful um that person was clearly not
very well at that point um one of the
limitations of A1 see is it doesn't tell
you how your blood sugar is ranging
throughout the day so because it is
essentially an
average you can have a so if you think
of it like grades in school if you got a
50 on one test and a 100 on another your
average is
75 but clearly you did terrible on one
particular day and very well on another
so similarly with A1C the range could be
that you're having lows and you're
having a highs and you're when C is
coming out okay that's not necessarily
the case but it can
be
I I don't think I am the best person to
answer what that threshold should
be um because I haven't been in practice
for two and a half well a little over
two years there may be folks here who
have some input on that and if not I
would be happy to get back to the
committee with the clinical guidelines
lines and a
recommendation I'm respectful of the
impact of required um of requirements on
insurance companies and I don't want to
make this so expensive that we can't get
it into law and help
people in the ideal World which of
course doesn't exist but if we had
unlimited funds I'd say everybody should
have it because they learn so much about
it and then they don't develop expensive
complications so regardless of whether
your A1C was 6.5 or
7.2 it logically makes sense to have but
we don't live in a world with unlimited
resources so I will seek a better answer
to that okay but in this case the device
that you're talking about is just doing
blood sugar it's not doing
A1C that is correct and we know that
your blood sugars can vary all day long
yes so the first time I got my little
kit which is you know you say as small
as it's even smaller than that it's very
small yeah right picking you know
pinning my skin was not a big got one it
specialized it it's just the right level
it's just it's really minor in my mind
the guy was probably afraid of blood but
at any rate um that that I I was taking
it all day long I really wanted to see
how much my blood sugar
fluctuated okay were you surp oh I'm
sorry I'm curious to ask if you were
surprised sometimes at what you saw when
you checked uh the the worst case I ever
got and and and I I announced I had
probably more than I should have had to
drink and I had I had one of those high
sugar high sugar drinks you know uh that
you know that's like Mike's Hard
Lemonade that's got like
236 sugars in it and it was dessert and
every it was the worst possible time and
I my number was
236 that's as high get it just to
highlight from that wonderful example
among those variables that affect blood
sugar alcohol mostly lowers blood sugar
not like we'd say to a patient drink
more to lower your sugar but nonset
alcoholic beverages mostly result in a
lower blood sugar but not in a
predictable time frame and way beer
usually raises blood sugar but not uh
uniformly and super sweet drinks like a
a mar
K who knows what's going to happen
236 or
457 so okay uh any other questions from
the committee yes representative miles
hi thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I understand you don't have a Excel
spreadsheet in front of you or anything
but can you tell the committee that's my
first question is can you tell the
committee approximately how much a uh
glucose machine that you can get on
Amazon or Target might be somewhere
around we have an analysis that I can
give you I'm just asking her a question
I'm sorry thanks thank you for the
question it's an excellent
question so there's more than one part
to the system just your average one get
in a box the um sensors are essentially
disposable they last for S to 14 days
depending on the product and then you
need a new one they won't work after
that it just stops providing so like to
$50
is I'm going to defer fol more current
in practice than me but it's more that
kind of detail we will get we'll get in
that we will get you that information
and then just to the other part of that
is you need some kind of reader yeah
trying to get at is the significantly
increased cost of the sensors including
like a Dexcom sensor they're not just
that those few little pieces those
include a transmitter a sensor the
strips are much more expensive and um my
concern is that as We Know Nothing is
for free and in the bill I noticed that
it does state that the patient won't be
subject to deductible but they certainly
will be subject to higher co- shares and
co-payments um so in the world of more
individualized medicine I'm concerned
that this might be Overkill in making it
an A1C qualifier or some other
qualifier I'm not sure what the some
other means I'm trying to think
creatively on the spot um I think we
could mitigate that to some
extent I had some conversation earlier
deductible as I noted in my initial
remarks people with diabetes have
medical expenses is that are at least
two and a half times that of folks who
do not have
diabetes and it's chronic and ongoing
it's never going to end for
them
if we change the language
deductible it won't benefit anywhere
near as many people because some of
those folks will be paying out of pocket
and will simply not be able to access
it so to be quite Frank I'm I'm on the
fence about whether that's a good change
to make in the bill I very much want to
help people with diabetes have access to
this technology that's so
valuable and I don't want to be foolish
enough to be stuck in a hard place and
then not help anybody yeah so more
conversation I guess yeah maybe some
hard guard rails around it perhaps okay
I I'm very willing to talk further thank
else when when you get when you stop
pointing your fingers at each other
which who's going to
speak do you think it would be helpful
if um the bill was changed on from page
two um section three talked about
subject to deductible from eliminating
that that Clause that it not be subject
to the
deductible thank you for your question
can you just direct me to the line
you're on yeah I'm on page two it goes
from line 13 oh right okay
um and this actually reminds me the bill
may look like it's redundant because
it's exactly the same for three sections
one for individual one for group and one
for HMO uh Managed Care um so just to
clarify that I meant to say that earlier
so
line I think my answer is going to be
whether to make it subject to deductible
is a decision for the committee to make
based on the data that you receive from
my followup from what representative
spear offered and from the folks behind
me
um if the data on reflection of the
nitty-gritty details
looks like it's not an unmanageable ask
for insurance companies to cover it
without deductible I would certainly
prefer
that but I would exempt those lines and
the parallel ones in the other parts of
the bill if need be to get some statute
of this sort
passed
you yes uh thank you Mr chairman uh
question do you know of any states that
have uh this bill or similar type Bill
uh how many states and what are they
thank you for that excellent question
and I knew the answer to that more
precisely when we brought this forward
last
time there are states that have this
yes and I'm not going to trust myself to
accurately tell you who they are at this
moment I apologize but I will get that
seeing no more questions thank you very
much thank you all and thank you for
your work and attention Okay the chair
we'll call on representative Jody n who
I assume is a co-sponsor of the
bill yes she
is good morning good morning um thank
you Mr chair and thanks to the committee
for giving me a little bit of your time
and attention today I'm a co-sponsor in
this bill very enthusiastically because
uh glucose monitoring equipment is
frankly my mother's Lifeline um it uh
she had a series of strokes and um you
know that changes a little bit in in how
you function um how you are able to keep
track of things so my dad does as much
as he possibly can but um you know she
needs to test regularly to make sure
that um her levels are in line um if she
doesn't test I get a call from the nurse
because neither one of my parents like
to answer the phone um and uh I get a
call from the nurse and if the numbers
are off too much she's in the hospital
which she has been fairly often um so I
think you know we uh talk about dollars
and cents and we talk about you know um
a variety of things but really what I
wanted to bring to it was um the
personal because uh my mom means the
world to me and it's equipment like this
that keeps her uh safe and healthy so
thank you thank you for your
testimony thank
good morning everyone um please bear
with me I'm going to read part of my
testimony because I really don't want to
repeat everything that hope has already
said but I'd be happy to answer any of
your questions um I'm a certified
Diabetes Care and education specialist
similar to the uh credentials that hope
held until recently uh although I'm
currently retired I have maintained my
credentials because I feel very strongly
about
managing um the care of individuals with
diabetes and providing them with the
education that they need I have been a
certified Diabetes Care education
specialist since
1986 I have worked in inpatient settings
I've worked in outpatient settings I
have dealt with pediatric patients type
2 patients patients with gestational
diabetes uh patients in rehab settings
Etc
um when I entered my career uh as a
diabetes educator we did not have blood
glucose monitoring we actually had to
test urine to determine where the
glucose was which was the only tool we
had but it was highly
ineffective uh in establishing diabetes
control and then in the late
1980s um blood glucose monitoring became
uh
uh became available to us and actually
there was a study that was done in which
ended in 1993 which is called the
diabetes control and complications trial
and that trial actually proved for
individuals with type 1 diabetes who
kept their diabetes well controlled they
could reduce the risk of complications
dramatically there was a 60% drop in
diabetic retinopathy which is eye
disease which can cause individuals with
diabetes to go blind there was a
significant drop in nerve damage caused
by diabetes which we call peripheral uh
peripheral neuropathy okay by 60% so
people that had numbness and tingling in
their feet for years and years and years
as they got their diabetes under better
control that numbness and tingling went
away they had sensation in their feet
that had been lost for a long period of
time
if you can just imagine having sensation
return to your feet okay prior to um
blood glucose monitoring I had a
particular gentleman who was a car
mechanic and um he went to work every
day okay he wanted to support his family
he got a nail which penetrated the his
boot okay and he did not feel the nail
in his boot until he had been walking on
it for a 24-hour period of time okay
that's how bad the neuropathy was okay
ultimately his leg could not be saved
and he became an amputee unfortunately
he had this experience twice he became a
double amputee because of a blister on
his other leg I could go on and on and
tell you stories but that's one of the
reasons I am such an advocate of blood
glucose monitoring during the time that
it existed and still exists
but even more so an advocate for
individuals with diabetes to have access
to continuous blood glucose
monitoring all those hospitalizations
and situations that I've described and
we'll describe a little bit further are
extremely costly amputation is costly
heart disease is costly blindness is
costly okay it limits people ability to
be able to be
productive
um the technology has come a long way
and CGM or continuous blood blood
glucose monitoring is part of that
state-of-the-arts when we check blood
sugar it's a snapshot in time it tells
you at a moment in time where your blood
sugar is at it does not tell you whether
it's going up or down whether it's
dangerously low and you're about ready
to crash your car because your blood
sugar is low okay or as hope gave the
example you got to throw your chainsaw
aside before you pass out from low blood
sugar I've encountered many individuals
who have crashed their cars because of
low blood sugar okay they were not able
continuous blood glucose monitoring
gives you a a picture quickly of where
your blood sugar is at and quite frankly
okay it allows the person with diabetes
to be more productive I'm going to give
you the one example of one of my clients
okay who was a waitress okay when she
developed type 2
diabetes okay it was very difficult
during rush hour for her to be able to
check her blood glucose okay because
what she would have needed to do because
of quote unquote the yuck factor of
blood particularly in a restaurant
setting if you can imagine okay she had
to go away someplace to test her blood
sugar which means that all those people
that are out there waiting to be served
and have their lunch okay had to wait a
little while longer well that was not
that really didn't make her boss very
happy however if she had a continuous
blood glucose monitoring system she
could literally swipe her reader or her
phone
over her sensor and know exactly where
her blood sugar was at at that moment in
time and she would have an idea okay of
where her blood sugar was at and whether
she really need to excuse herself to get
something to eat or whether she could
work for the next half hour till things
slowed
down the American Diabetes Association
in their 2025 standards of care
recommends CGM
for those with type 2 diabetes not only
those on insulin but those on other
medications for diabetes they have not
recommended it for those that are
treated with diet alone and quite
honestly there is technology available
that can be purchased by people with
pre-diabetes
okay um or those people that have type
two diabetes one of them is called Stell
which is made by the same company that
makes uh that makes the Dexcom 7 okay
that Dexcom 7 is intended for
individuals that on medication for
diabetes but the problem the Stell one
of the things that it does not do okay
and it isn't really necessary at this
point in time is to give the individual
with diabetes alerts whereas a
Dexcom uh seven okay or freestyle Libre
which are two of probably the one of of
the most popular
uh uh continuous blood monitoring
systems can also give individuals alerts
so we did not put that into the bill to
include individuals that treated with
diet alone we put into the bill
individuals that could be on other forms
of treatment because that's what the
American Diabetes Association has
recommended quite frankly I know a
number of individuals okay that are
currently using Okay continuous blood
glucose monitoring systems who have been
on insulin in the past okay they're now
off insulin because they have started a
new category of drugs called gp1s okay
these are the drugs we see advertised on
TV OIC being one of them you know we
recognize that the some of these drugs
are very costly and not everyone
necessarily has them okay however people
are fearful that if they come off of
insulin they will no longer be able to
have access to the continuous blood
glucose monitoring
system because they are now off insulin
now what about the individual where the
glp ones work okay for a short period of
time and then they don't work
hospitalization as an example they're
back on insulin again they really want
those that they really continue to need
to monitor their blood sugars so I hate
to do this but you're you're over your
five minutes obvious okay I apologize
can you kind of wrap it up I will wrap
it up I will wrap it up with uh
gestational diabetes okay
uh it has been described by hope very
well a person with gational diabetes
okay has um a high risk of giving birth
to children that have a lot of problems
large babies babies that experience
hypoglycemia and by hypoglycemia I'm
talking about sometimes seizing after
birth for up to 24 to 48 hours because
they can't get the baby's blood sugar up
to a safe and normal range
okay people with gational diabetes need
to test before they eat they need to
test two hours after each of their meals
that's very very difficult to do to say
nothing of the people that are extremely
afraid of needles and I have encountered
many individuals in my years in practice
that actually have passed out as we're
trying to teach them to test their blood
sugar and unfortunately have had bad
outcomes to their pregnancy because of
that I apologize for going over as you
can see I'm pretty passionate about what
I say um but I would be welcome I would
welcome any questions
yeses whoever whoever gives permission
sorry thank you um thank you for sharing
the stories about the severe effects
that diabetes can have on people and
it's tragic um I'm wondering from your
experience or actually from anyone who
can answer this what is the current
medical necessity criteria to get the
Dexcom mon The Continuous blood glucose
system I see I a lot of people have it
so what is the current medical necessity
criteria for which they're able to get
it currently okay the the current
medical necessity would be a diagnosis
of diabetes you cannot get the Dexcom 7
if you have pre-diabetes okay just as an
example you cannot get it if you're
controlled by diet alone so you could
have type two diabetes controlled by
diet alone or pre-diabetes you cannot
get it that's where individuals are now
going with this other system system
which is called Stell okay which it's an
over-the-counter product follow up for
the F the question um so as as as it
stands we don't know if there's any
numerical qualitative quantitative
guidelines like the A1C or the glucose
the 90-day average you don't have any of
that as a part of that medical necessity
currently it is uh it is it it is based
on diagnosis okay at this point it has
to be the doctor diagnosis the doctor
has had to make a diagnosis of diabetes
okay and you know these standards have
just changed as far as these new
medications are concerned so the studies
are not really there yet regarding the
outcomes of of what will happen um you
know we we know we know okay for those
of us that have worked in the field that
it is extremely helpful to monitor where
your blood sugars are at thank you thank
you very
much chair will call on Jason
a ziz who uh represents the insurance
department and as usual they will be
legislation good morning Mr chair thank
you for the record Jason AIS director of
Health Economics New Hampshire insurance
department professor of physical
activity nutrition and health at T
University Unity school of medicine and
diabetic so I just wanted to make clear
that I think the um representative miles
question about the eligibility criteria
is positive diagnosis of diabetes could
be either with the hemoglobin A1c 6.4%
or over an or orog glucose tolerance
test or fast in plasma glucose test that
a positive for diabet abetes um and
currently on insulin therapy thank it's
not worthy that the two there was really
the two things yeah those two conditions
and so it's noteworthy that Medicare
just in um April of 2024 reduced the
rigors of the insulin therapy
requirement from three um multiple daily
injections to only one per day so
there's a a whole class of long acting
insulin bio or insulin secretor extended
release yeah okay so we wrote a fiscal
note on this and I think we did one last
year um and the I think the fiscal
impact largely would be the same as in a
fiscal note and um you know I think
that's the extent of the testimony we're
neutral on this bill if the anyone here
answer uh fiscal notes say zero do we
one to the extent that this is an
expanded um benefit requirement for
essential health benefits it would be
subject to the federal cost def frail
right and so and to the extent that it
would
increase um the frequency of
prescription for cgms technology it
would provide upward pressure on
premiums to the extent it's
indeterminable at this time oh yeah that
doesn't tell me much but okay
okay the marginal cost is between $800
to $1,200 per unit per year so oh we are
going to go to subcommittee so all these
issues will get fully vetted in the
subcommittee okay but right now we're
running short on time and I certainly
don't want to be here by
noon in case anybody has diabetes issues
much uh Sabrina Dunlap from Anthem who
is in opposition to the
Lindsay evidently Senate Health and
Human Services is meeting at the same
time good morning everyone I'm Lindsay
NATO um I'm an attorney from Orin Reno
and we represent siga as mentioned
Sabrina asked me to pass along um her
apologies we are double booked this
morning and there's a bunch of Health
bills in Senate HHS right now as well um
so I wasn't planning on speaking so I'm
going off the top of my head here from
last year but I will just point out a
couple concerns that um siga has and I
think some of the other carriers share
um with the bill and so just keeping in
mind generally the testimony we heard
last year from uh and information from
the medical community is that the
medical necessity for these devices for
type 2 diabetes is still up in the air
and so I think that's a concern right
we're really talking about whether these
devices are medically necessary for type
2 diabetes and I think that's where
there's concern that the bill is overly
broad um uh my understanding is that
plans generally cover them when
medically necessary for type 1 diabetes
already um so in that sense I think this
may be a bill in you know one of those
um it's a solution in search of a
problem in that sense um the other thing
I just would point out is anytime we
have bills that say they're going to
limit um application to a deductible or
co-pays or other cost sharing that's
concerning because those costs then
generally drive up costs quicker to the
overall plans um and so we do think this
would have um upward pressure on costs
and
premiums I would also note um I'm not
quite sure how logistically parts of the
bill would work um there's mentioned
that to qualify for
coverage um people would need to stay on
a continued course of treatment for 6 12
or 18 months and so then the question
arises what happens if they don't do you
claw back coverage I don't think we
could or would do that but that's just a
logistical problem I haven't quite seen
anything like that drafted in our
insurance laws
before um and just generally um you know
mandates do cause upward pressure on
premiums so we do always get concerned
with uh
mandates I would also point out to the
extent that the um Bill impacts the
Medicaid plan certainly should talk to
HHS about what those costs would be
there's no Medicaid okay sorry someone
mentioned that
earlier um and would also just just
qualify that would everybody understand
this under the Affordable Care
Act the um Marketplace which is
insurance for
individuals which some people might
think is Medicare okay but it's
technically you know it is a separate
little market that and I always say I
wish I was a fly on the wall when they
tried to figure this one out but what
they did was for each state they put a
stake in the ground and they say any new
health insurance mandate going
state yeah proceed and and that may have
been where the confusion is and I think
that's um noted in the Department's
fiscal note um so that's just something
something to keep in mind um but happy
to try to answer any questions and if I
don't have the answers I will get them
in circle
back okay representative
sharan U thanks for taking a question uh
you mentioned that uh very generically
that the premium will go up I mean
that's very generic you know uh outcome
but have you done any analysis as to how
much premium will go up if this is
covered thank you for the question I
last year um last year's Bill the
department did a pretty in-depth
analysis and I'm looking at rep spear
who knows more about that um so that's
something we could certainly distribute
to the committee thank you yeah the
subcommittee will take that
up was you have the number off your head
I have the numbers what was the number
the yes okay you have to understand how
the number got derived okay Dr AIS gave
me the numbers for how much it costs for
each for these units AR range for those
units correct we said in the individual
Market oh and he also gave me the upt
uptake numbers for type one diabetes
assuming that the type one diabetes
uptake is the same as the type two which
26% it will cost based on those things
over the 20 uh 2,000 no 200,000 people
that are subscribers that are in the
small Market the individual market and
the large large group Market covered by
full insurance in the state that we have
any control over comes out to about $23
a year $23 per year which is $2 a month
which is about $2 a month that's what
the cost is okay thank you any other
questions
for all right representative M thank you
just to take it one step further has
there been any uh cost benefit analysis
in other words um the outcomes of people
they the health outcomes of people that
are apparently on this monitoring device
are significantly better I understand
but has anybody actually looked at that
or made projections I see a nod back
there I'd like to hear about that thank
you for the question so I'm probably not
the person to answer that um but it
sounds like folks behind me probably
could I think when you're when you're
looking at mandates that's always a
question right is what is the cost
benefit analysis because there's a lot
of mandates that in and themselves might
seem like they cost just a little bit
but you have to remember they add up
quickly and so we're looking at right
now in Senate HHS is a biomarker mandate
there's a whole bunch of mandates every
single year that get considered and so
when you're doing that cost benefit
analysis it's important to look at not
only uh this mandate but overall what
are the cost drivers um in the market
but that's uh a good question represent
Sullivan thank you for taking my
question you said in your testimony that
for type one one you is medically
necessary is there ever a case where
type two is medically necessary um yes
the answer is if you've been di
diagnosed being a
diabetic A and B you're on insulin okay
and I I would also point out right so
anytime that you are um say you're type
two but your doctor thinks you need this
and they give you a prescription for it
and um if you were to be denied there
are appeals processes
internally and then externally through
all the health insurance plans and so if
you are one of those unique scenarios
where it is medically necessary for you
there's a process that you can go
through through your carrier to get that
approved okay represent spear the
analysis that was done was done without
a
deductible so if the insurance company
needs to put on a deductible depending
on what kind of plan you purchased that
number goes down so that's the maximum
number right
okay represent
sha um thank you again actually I just
want to follow up uh maybe I'm not too
clear when you say medically necessary I
heard two things either you're diagnosed
I mean you're diagnosed with the
diabetes is it and your on insulin or is
it or your
insulin right now I don't know answer to
that I'm sorry and you've been diagnosed
as
diabetic and the The Physician is now
giving you insulin and the idea was the
purpose of these test kits is to see how
the insulin is working because it can yo
yo and the reason why I said is because
they were the reason why I said that as
the question because I we don't we don't
want we'll take it up in subcommittee we
don't want we don't want is that is that
accurate or because I I don't think
that's accurate because uh I that's
something you can take up in the commit
sub okay and I would just know right so
um from the from a health plans
perspective we're following National
guidelines for what's medically
necessary so um I think part of the
problem with this bill is that that
hasn't been decided yet in the type two
realm exactly among the medical
community okay I I I just thought the
first part is only necessary if you
diagnos diabetes is medically necessary
that's what my understanding was so far
right thank you okay thank you all right
uh chair will'll call on uh Nancy
Beerman and you didn't say how much time
you'll take but I hope you'll be brief
and not say anything that's already been
said representative Aman knows I'm never
brief
right uh Nancy Beerman um I'm
representing myself um just to also let
you know I am a member of the New
Hampshire rare disease advisory Council
what what is that I'm sorry the New
Hampshire rare disease advisory ccil
disease okay but I'm not representing
them but I have to say it um I am a
mother of a type 1 diabetic um she was
diagnosed in 2006 at the age of five um
very scary um until you meet other
parents when their children were
diagnosed as infants um she was able to
get a pump in 2010 which changed our
lives um but in order to get that pump I
had to fight the insurance companies um
because I was taking too good of care of
her her A1C was below the limit we had
to fight and fight the insurance
companies um to get her eligible for a
pump because I was doing too well um
being doing too well means that I was
giving her finger sticks 8 to 10 almost
sometimes when she was sick up to 20
times a day um on a normal day we would
be doing finger sticks before and after
meals we'd also be doing and taking
turns with my husband and doing
nighttime checks um which included um
before her going to bed another check at
10 o'clock at night another check at 2
am another check at 5:00 am. and then
another check at 7 a.m. when uh we got
her ready for school so um
for four to five years we were
constantly doing that until we got the
pump um the pump afforded us a little
bit more flexibility but we still were
doing the checks um until we could get
the pump regulated um in about 2016 we
were able to get a continuous glucose
monitor and that changed our lives again
um because we could see where she was
trending and see where her blood sugar
was going um for people that um T tried
to group all the diabetes together
they're all different monsters in my
viewpoint um but what you have to
realize with A continuous glucose
monitor it allows people to see what
foods react to them and how it affects
their blood sugar so what reacts and
makes your blood sugar go high doesn't
make me go High and um and so we um one
instance uh we had always gone to a
certain pizza place and gotten pizza and
um my daughter we had it dialed in one
slice of pizza is this many carbs um all
of a sudden it wasn't working anymore so
I went up to the pizza uh guy and I said
hey did you change your recipe and he's
like yeah we did he's like is it tasting
different I said no it's just affecting
my daughter's blood sugar and he's like
really and I said yeah so I mean
something that simple that you don't
even know that a restaurant changed the
recipe will change your um glucose and
cause issues um after she got uh her
continuous glucose uh monitor um the
first time we went back to
endocrinologist and we got the readout
her numbers were like perfectly in range
um that readout is on her doctor's wall
um and in fact uh she still is in range
um when she had to move up from
pediatric uh doctors into adult doctors
um one of the first adult ones she saw
was the eye doctor and he is just
absolutely impressed with at her having
absolutely no eye disease at all at her
age so and having you know she's spent
20 years with this disease anyone prior
to having these medical devices in 20
years would have other complic patients
so these two um devices now the current
CGM and um and she also got a a new pump
they communicate with each other so we
got that right before she went off to
college and that was just life-saving to
me another great thing because I didn't
have to worry about her going low
overnight and her roommate not realizing
um she did have one low situation where
we had to call Public Safety um but that
was because she was sick and um and her
roommate was home for the weekend uh so
but again they the more and more
technology advances keep her safer every
single day and I will say that we've
only had one hospital admission in 20
years so that's saving your insurance
company money um so that she hasn't had
any chance of developing complications
or going into keto
acidosis um and we're just just happy
with the technology that's out there and
so is she so Dexcom has been a lifesaver
and um they've also just with the G7
it's updated and made it more usable and
friendly and less pieces to be involved
which makes it easier for her to do it
um but yeah and as far as the money goes
um prior to yeah uh we had insurance
that has a deductible it's $6,000 so
we've literally already paid for a
college education for her through her
diabetes um diabetes is one of the most
expensive diseases out there because of
the long-term uh necessity for it and um
so every year by February March we've
paid her 6,000 deductible um insulin
used to be $1,000 per month um then you
add on your pump supplies that's another
$1,000 a month and then you add on your
CDM and that was also about $1,000 per
month so you reach that $6,000 Mark
pretty quickly and um um we would
appreciate and I'm sure every other
parent would appreciate having those
numbers decreased I would also as she's
getting old enough to go off of our
insurance I would appreciate the cost of
her uh chronic condition to be costing
her less as I'm not sure what insurance
she'll be able to get as an adult in in
the world and what insurance will cover
or not cover um as we find out more and
more kids between um going off their
parents' insurance and getting a job
that has good insurance for them and
covers more of it they are um dying
because they can't afford just even the
basic insulin because of the cost of it
um so please try to make everything less
cost it costs less for each of these
children especially in that time frame
thank you I thought we passed a law that
limited to $100 a month yes more
recently okay so the numbers giving our
right but that's a concern as a parent
that I lived with right until more
recently yes but in terms of people are
going to want to know what do it cost
now more recently yes those numbers have
gone down in fact the first time I got
an insurance uh got a bill from for
insulin and found out I I literally
called him up and said did the insurance
company said did you push the wrong
button I mean how is this so less when
we were so used to paying so much each
year and stuff I mean when we brought
her home from the hospital we couldn't
bring her home without having all of the
medical drugs and everything and the
pharmacist looking at me he like can you
afford all this I mean that was a very
Hefty
Bell great thank you very much all right
uh okay Andrew Hosmer representing
Harvard
brief thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Andrew Hosmer I'm
here with representing Harvard Pilgrim
Healthcare which is New Hampshire's
largest nonprofit Health insurer um
certainly appreciate the work the
representative Damon's done in this bill
and also the testimony from the previous
uh people who sat before you um I I do
want to let you know that Harvard
Pilgrim uh is opposed to this bill um
and just to touch on a couple of brief
talking points here if I may Harvard
Pilgrim currently covers blue uh uh
blood glucose monitors and continuous
long-term glucose monitoring devices our
coverage criteria are based on medical
necessity for those patients who need a
GL glucose monitor due to insulin
utilization Andor frequency of blood
glucose testing uh I also want to point
out too one of the issues that came up
was uh gestational diabetes uh Harvard
Pilgrim considers continuous glucose
monitoring systems as reasonable and
medically necessary for Gest diabetes
for the duration of a pregnancy um
naturally the uh the CGM must be
prescribed by a professional provider
with experience in treating gestational
diabetes uh this bill however would
expand existing coverage and require
coverage of glucose monitoring devices
and supplies to individuals with
diabetes that do not currently use
insulin therapy and for whom a
continuous glucose monitor may not be
medically
necessary removal of prior authorization
requirements also limits Health Plan's
ability to ensure that our members are
receiving the right treatment at the
right time there have been concerns
already raised I won't repeat them about
the deductible and one of the concerns
finally that we have in this bill as
well is that the bill requires specific
patient follow-up care that may be
challenging for the carrier to uh make
sure that the patient is complying with
and then continue to authorize the the
coverage for the needed services and
materials
with that I'm happy to take questions um
like represent shes yeah actually this
is follow up the first question I was
trying to ask when you define is is the
definition of medical necessity is it
different for insurance company versus
the medical providers because the reason
why I'm saying is that my wife she has
diabetes and uh she's not an insulin
however her doctor did say that she
should have the CGM of course the
insurance not not paying for it so we
are paying from our pocket but the
question but but the question is that
the medical provider uh decided that
this is medical necessary to have her
fian however the insurance company has a
different criteria to Define medical
necessity how are those two medical
necessity criteria are different I I I
appreciate the question and and
obviously I couldn't speak to you
specifically to your wife's situation so
I can't shed any light on that what I
will say is that Harvard uh Pilgrim uh
considers long-term continuous glucose
monitoring systems as reasonably and
medically necess necessary for diabetes
when all of the protocols that they have
worked to put in place which follows a
National Standard are met um we do
believe that is a consistency though
between the provider and the carrier on
a number of issues um a number of
diseases and number of diagnosis that
may be met so the idea is to maintain
some consistency there um certainly we
are the the carrier not the practitioner
or the provider but we try to have an a
relationship with all of the pro
providers that can deliver the best care
to those covered lives that are members
of the Harvard Pilgrim Health
Plan just to follow quick question so so
just just follow on that so are you are
you implying that the medical necessity
definition from the medical providers
and the insurance company is is same at
this point I I can't speak to it
specifically I can say that you can
strive the certainly both providers and
carriers will strive to have a
consistent um definition of medical
necessity based on the diagnosis in this
instance here I will say that the uh
Harvard Pilgrim is filing uh following
excuse me national standards uh for this
and believes that this is the best
determining this medical necessity
delivers the best care for its patients
that are covered thank you welcome okay
represent Walts thank you Mr chairman
uh thank you for taking my question I
don't know for certain if you can answer
it I was just wondering do you know what
year cgm's came to the marketplace I'm
sorry I can't answer that and if you
like though I'm happy to try and find
that information and provide it to the
committee
sorry thank you very much thank you I
have one card left Jean Brown from gtown
in support of the bill oh this is you're
going to read the other one okay uh can
we just get it in the file
get since you've already testified I
can't you can put it the file I've
distributed a copy of this to everybody
here okay we're all set then all right
great then we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill
648 and we'll quickly reopen the hearing
on
678 and did you fill out a card okay
okay so we have the prime
sponsor representative Greg uh good
morning still morning yes it is still
morning good morning for the record I'm
Alicia Greg I represent naswa Ward 7 I'm
actually here about House Bill 678 today
and I'm also here to not waste your time
so after talking to people on both
spectrums of this we have some
significant amendments that will be
coming that will completely change this
bill um so I'm just going to ask you
today if you would please retain this so
that way I don't waste anybody's time
and we bring to you some good
legislation that we can discuss at a
later
date great thank you very much sorry to
make you wait for
that okay uh no that's
648 okay so she hasn't filled it out yet
okay and this is so Point she she is
asking us to retain the bill not to take
action okay so next is uh Brandon gared
morning Mr chairperson members of the
committee my name is Brandon Gad I a
senior Assistant Attorney General chief
of the consumer protection and anti
trust Bureau at the New Hampshire
Department of Justice um come before you
I understand this bill is being retained
so I will also try to be brief but I do
think whatever amendments are submitted
it is important to consider um my
testimony is not in for or against the
merits of this bill but um expressing
concern about its placement under New
Hampshire's consumer protection act the
way this bill was drafted and the way
many bills are drafted any violation
would be an unfair deceptive actor
practice in violation of 358 A2 um that
has consequences that I think might not
be fully understood by the folks who
drafted this and possibly by the members
of this committee and what I mean by
that is New Hampshire's consumer
protection act lists a number of
delineated violations so if you do this
thing it is considered a violation of
the statute it also has a general
prohibition that says any unfair or
deceptive act or practice is also a
violation gives the Attorney General the
authority to bring criminal actions to
bring civil actions to issue subpoenas
to investigate um and the way that we
figure out what is a general unfair or
deceptive actor practice um courts have
issued a lot of guidance on this one of
the critical factors though is they look
to the types of things that have been
expressly listed in the statute
as unfair and deceptive Acts or practice
and they ask the question is this new
thing of the same kind that is
prohibited by the statute and most of
the things that are prohibited are
deceptive practices you know selling
something and making claims about it
that aren't true um Contracting for
something that you have no ability to
provide or no reason to believe you can
provide but if you add things that are
different than the things that are
currently listed it has the potential
for the statute to expand to include
things that I don't think the
legislature intended it to include and
in this case what is trying to be done
is to prohibit or limit the sale of
certain things to Miners And there's an
extensive history in this state and
throughout the country of limiting what
can and can't be sold to miners but that
doesn't mean that they're also
violations of the consumer protection
act it's unlawful to sell cigarettes to
miners but it doesn't mean that it's an
unfair and deceptive actor practice it's
unlawful to sell I believe lottery
tickets to miners alcohol to miners
various other things that doesn't mean
that doing so is an unfair deceptive
actor practice there are other
consequences for those actions but by
making a violation of the consumer
protection act simply a Prohibition
against selling something to minors it
creates an argument that selling tobacco
products to miners is also an unfair and
deceptive actor practice selling
fireworks to miners is also an unfair
deceptive actor practice selling weapons
to Miners and also an unfair and
deceptive actor practice and I don't
think that that is anybody's intention
here so this if this is a type of
prohibition that the legislature is
interested in pursuing and there very
well may be Merit to it I think that
it's wrongfully placed under the
consumer protection act in the
legislature should think carefully about
what type of enforcement or Consequences
um are more appropriate for simply
something that prohibits the sale of
something to a minor and make it more in
line with those laws that already
Express such prohibitions so happy to
take any questions at this time I
okay thank you all thank you for
Robert from the Department of Health and
Human
Services under our food protection
section thank you chairman hunt members
of the committee my name is Michelle
robers I'm the bureau chief for Public
Health protection within the division of
Public Health Services at the Department
of Health and Human Services um I I
understand that this may this bill may
be retained we have some testimony um
that we were going to share today would
you like us to provide that or if it's
written testimony yeah we can yeah
distribute I have copies here as well
and um Erica Davis I'll let
her good morning thank you members of
the committee my name is Erica Davis um
for the record I'm the administrator of
the food protection section um within
the Department of Health and Human
Services um uh Public Health
division um so this proposed legislation
would require retail stores to post um
at each of the counter
locations
um information
um about health concerns for dietary
supplements weight loss um and muscle
building um this as noted in the
Department's fiscal note um we're not
able to estimate the precise fiscal
impact um because we can't determine the
number of retail establishments that may
be impacted by this
legislation the department only has
information for retail establishments
that are required to be licensed by the
department um under the food protection
section RSA 143a we licens about 4,900
food establishments approximately 11 00
of those food establishments are
considered retail Food
Stores um this does not include the 15
self- inspecting cities and towns who
license and inspect uh retail
establishments and this would not
include retail establishments that have
no food that require refrigeration for
safety and would not be required to be
licensed by the department examples of
these locations would be GNC's or
vitamin
stores as written the department would
be respons for developing and providing
notice that clearly communicates the
health concerns of these
products based on the understanding of
the department we originally placed the
fiscal impact between $10,000 and
$100,000 per for fiscal year
2026 um and estimated that would be less
in future years um as long as the
department wasn't required to create new
uh posters for these counter locations
after further review of the bill there
are concerns about the definition of
dietary
supplement there is concerns that um
specifically dietary supplements for
weight loss or muscle building that are
intended to be included in this list
legislation could be interpreted in
various ways and expand the list um that
impacts
retailers the division Department would
also like to note that we haven't
researched any of these Health claims um
identified and proposed in this
legislation um and therefore could be
broadly applied to supplements would
which not be helpful for consumers to
make an informed choice in order for the
Department to develop uh informative and
useful messaging we' need to research
these Health claims and make sure
that
um the individual supplements would fall
under legislation would be accurately
represented in this um poster
at this point we would not be able to
define the cost of the department um
with this uh further
research and I would just uh add that at
this point the department isn't taking a
position on the bill but we just wanted
to relay our concerns and we did share
the same written testimony with uh the
bill sponsor as
well happy to take any questions so um
so when I read this bill
um again I have the curse of being
around too long uh I immediately thought
about what happened with psea FEDS
because psea feds was an
over-the-counter
drug and then all of a sudden we said
nope we're pulling it back and we're
putting it behind the counter the
pharmacy counter and yes if you're under
18 or 21 you can't buy it and and for
those of us who are over we got to show
our driver's license and we can only get
so much was that statue are you guys
involved was that purely the pH was that
a pharmaceutical statue that that okay I
I don't think so we we are focused on
the food protection side right so yeah
I'm getting it is pharmace from the boss
yeah that's right our counterpart in the
back we know each other
well okay so that answers that question
all
right thank you very much thank you
thank you you okay I have one more card
fry and he has left the room and he has
no
position uh but it looks like he had a
question so
we'll answer that question when we go to
subcommittee okay so just to understand
the way we we do things here in Commerce
everything will go to a subcommittee and
at that point in time we'll see where
you're at and and whether you know you
have something to amend we can we can
get our arms around otherwise we will
just move to retain the bill okay and
but it happens in sub committee and then
the full by the time we take it up with
the full committee we've already have
decided what was the best outcome so
with that I will close the public
hearing look at
that question on this he wasn't here he
you
e
we'll open up the public
hearing on House Bill 639 and here from
Ammon good afternoon
good afternoon hello Commerce and Mr
chair it's the best looking Committee in
the whole state
house uh so for the record my name is
Keith Ammon I represent Hillsboro
District 42 that's New Boston Mount
Vernon and line bro so thank you for
your Indulgence this is my third and
final blockchain related bill for the
year and this one is uh it's called the
blockchain basics law so what I thought
thought I might do was just give you a
high level overview on the bill the the
ideas in this bill came from several
places um one we had that uh commission
that Governor sonunu uh issued had a
report with recommendations and some of
the recommendations that we haven't
implemented are in this bill so sort of
a clean up the remaining recommendations
there's also language borrowed from
model laws that are circulating in other
states uh and then
some some uh definitions that kind of
knit it all
together all right so uh one disclaimer
uh I do own digital assets and I'm also
the chair of the New Hampshire
blockchain Council which is a new
nonprofit volunteer
organization so the overview I passed
out written testimony for you can save
it for
later uh section one is the purpose and
finding section section two is the short
title which is the blockchain basics
laws section three has some definitions
in it that are related to
blockchain and some of those might look
familiar to you because they've they've
been in other legislation some of them
have so page three line 13 is where I'm
next yeah line 13 so I'm just going to
line 13 talks about holding and use of
private digital currency so this this
protects individuals rights to use
digital assets for payments and self-
custody which is an important concept
self- custody ensuring freedom and
reducing restrictions so that's what the
holding and use of digital a private
digital currency that section it
protects individual rights to hold and
use digital
assets uh
that's line 13 line 21 same page
infrastructure to run blockchain
protected this safeguards infrastructure
needed to run blockchain operations it
allows home and Industrial mining
operations to uh to exist and it
prevents against discriminatory
ordinances or electric
rates so in we've seen in some states uh
New York state in particular they wrote
special laws that would discriminate
against uh mining digital asset
mining operations so we would Proclaim
section and this is the right to private
keys so this is another important
concept for something called self-
custody so basically your key
uh represents your ownership over your
digital assets and if someone else were
to get that key they could they could
steal them they could move them to a an
account that you no longer
control so this is basically a privacy
aspect to the
bill uh the next section is Page four
line
19 and this this would recognize
blockchainbased
trusts they would be recognized and uh
someone who's a little more expert on
that will be speaking behind me but it
basically uses precedent from existing
trust laws that we have in New Hampshire
blockchain and let's
see page four line 37 is the beginning
networks this is about reducing
regulatory barriers
and providing certainty for
businesses and I won't dig into all the
details there but basically a blockchain
is a it's a decentralized network of
computers and each computer is called a
node and so for it to for it to work
there has to be lots of nodes lots of
places that all communicate with each
other and that's the hardware
operation so we're hearing a lot about
AI requires big computers to operate um
blockchain depending on the blockchain
requires you know similar computation in
order for it to
last so page six line 23 is just a
standard cability clause and that just
says if any section is struck down the
the remaining sections will still
exist and
would establish a blockchain dispute
Docket in our judicial system and that
is one of the
major remaining recommendations from the
governor's commission is
that and so the analogy is Delaware has
uh it's the home for to to register a
corporation and part of the reason is
because they have expertise in their
court system to solve disputes resolve
disputes around LLC law right and so if
we're going to be uh home to digital
asset industry in New Hampshire we want
to have expertise in the judicial system
around blockchain disputes there's a lot
of if you just peruse the definition
section you'll see that some expertise
is
required and finally effective dates uh
so the the blockchain dispute docket uh
will go into effect January 1st 2026 so
there's little less than a year to
establish that depending on when this
bill is signed and then the remainder is
60 days after
passage so that's my high Lev flyover
there's lots of different sections in
the bill but uh I'll stop there and
happy to answer any
questions thank you uh representative
spear
me last year we um reviewed and and
eventually developed laws around Dows
and this year we're going to give it a
shot with uh tokenized uh real world
assets and stable coins good job
everything's
great this bill has sections in it that
limits the ability of the
state to legislate certain limitations
on
blockchains in for instance in
environmental kind of stuff now the fact
that a blockchain is is run on a on
three computers isn't going to bother
anybody but when it starts getting very
large it can impact our electrical grid
which isn't the most stable in the
country it can impact our water supply
it can impact when it gets really big we
can be facing what they're facing in
Texas which is endless lawsuits over
noise water electrical grid and their
ours so my feeling is and and I want to
get your your opinion on this why aren't
we doing an investigation before we're
just throwing a bunch of laws out there
to see what the impact is on some some
of the stuff is no problem but some of
the stuff we need to we need to look at
this
so okay um I think I'm asking a question
yeah would you believe so I would
believe that um so the the idea in this
bill is that there wouldn't be
discriminatory action so like if if uh
the you know the the the rules around
connecting a large consumer to the
electric grid would apply equally to
blockchain companies as other companies
so the idea is that it it wouldn't it
wouldn't have no rules it just wouldn't
have special rules that Target that
specific industry and what it would do
is give confidence to the industry that
we're not going to discriminate against
them because it's happened in other
states can I follow follow up you made
this is a big conversation about energy
uh we've been legislating and and
dealing with those items that I talked
about before and now all of a sudden
we're getting into things that can be
cryptocurrency could be anything and we
haven't built any legislative stuff
around any of that and we haven't even
decided if we want any of that in the
state I'm not saying we wouldn't but you
know we haven't made those decisions yet
and all of a sudden we're giving
everybody cart blanch knock yourself out
so what's cart blanch about the bill
that's what I want to
understand I don't think that the city
of Nashua has ever come up with the
noise requirements in a neighborhood
before they never they never looked at
that I don't think we've ever looked at
we we we have bills around that talk
about micro grids that I see people
being evaluated yeah maybe what we want
to say is if they get a certain size get
your own micro grid maybe we want to say
no you can't take the whole
grid like they do in other states and
and face a bunch of lawsuits there's
some evaluation that needs to go on here
not
just sign up for stuff I so that's my
this this is anti-discriminatory
language it's not enabling it's not a
special carve out it's it's to protect
from it being targeted by people who
don't understand the energy consumption
issue because that's a very
counterintuitive issue and in Texas
there's the large mining operations and
they shut down when the demand on the
grid goes up so it's called a large
flexible
load I saw that remember what our
maximum is is one Meg right so our our
Energy prices in New Hampshire are
probably too high to have a lot of
mining here because it goes to where the
energy is cheap and in Texas they have a
lot of fossil fuels and big wind farms
so I don't I don't see that as being a
major issue in New Hampshire but it it
would send the signal that we're a
friendly State we're not going to crack
down because uh we heard we heard a you
know a
news article that was negative a lot of
the information we get in the media is
sort of
so
okay point taken representative
Gibbs thank you and thank you for coming
to testify this afternoon um I have a
number of questions about this bill and
I'm going to try and take them a couple
at a time so I don't take up the whole
hearing um and I'm afraid I have to
start with the definitions um on um page
three um lines 4 through uh 10 cover
smart contracts yes and um on lines nine
and
10 it says that a smart contract um is
the creation of irrevocable digital
arrangements and then says that a smart
contract need not meet the common law
requirements of a legal contract yeah if
it creates irrevocable Arrangements it
why doesn't it need to satisfy the
requirements of a
contract that's a very good question and
fortunately I think there are at least
two attorneys behind me that will
probably be able to answer that better
than I can but uh the technical point is
that a smart contract is irrevocable by
Nature it cannot be revoked and that's
one of the it's it's a property of
immutability that is uh sort of central
to blockchain Theory so no matter what
we we do we we can't possibly cancel a
smart contract on the blockchain it's
it's just not it's designed to resist
change so that's that's the technical
reason now why it's not considered a
legal contract I uh I think if you drew
a VIN diagram of what a legal contract
can do and what a smart contract can do
there might be some overlap um but a
smart contract isn't an analogous to a
legal contract that's my Layman's
heard a question you may inquire thank
you
um okay uh lines 11 and 12 on page three
it says staking means using a node to
lock digital Assets in order to operate
the consensus mechanism of a blockchain
protocol now I understand that a node is
a computer right but locking digital
Assets in order to operate the consensus
mechanism of a blockchain protocol could
you tell us what that means please yeah
that's a great great question uh so
representative Spears talked about
energy consumption on blockchain so the
central idea is something called a
consensus mechanism consensus mechanism
and what that mechanism does it's an
algorithm uh each node operator runs a
copy of the entire blockchain this is
the way it works on most blockchains
they each have a copy right and so
they're all trying to update their
information simultaneously so consensus
mechanism allows them to come to
agreement on what the next block is
going to be in the blockchain that's
what a consensus mechanism is so Bitcoin
and others like it use something called
proof of work proof of work and that's
computers crunching trying to solve
basically a big riddle and that's how
and the first one to come to that answer
gets the block okay staking is a is a
different kind of consensus mechanism
it's called proof of stake and how proof
of stake works
and why people like it that are
concerned about energy consumption is it
doesn't require as much energy as proof
of work does it's sort of like an uh an
environmental upgrade on a consensus
mechanism so how staking works is let's
say you have a
so the foundational idea is that
blockchains cannot work without
incentives and the incentives are the
native token to that blockchain that's
the incentive that's the thing that has
everyone cooperating to to maintain the
system in proof of stake the node has
basically a treasury on it it's not
really called a treasury but you can
think of it like a treasury and people
take their assets they put it on that
node that's called
staking if that node becomes a bad actor
in the consensus if it tries to steal
defraud the the rest of the network
punishes that node and then it's called
a slashing event all of that stake you
know either gets destroyed or
distributed back to the rest of the
system that node gets punished for being
a bad actor so in to to incentivize
staking when the node participates in
accurate blocks a little bit of of those
units get rewarded to the stakers
usually in proportion to how much they
have stake it's sort of like interest on
a bank account so as long as that node
is operating
accurately and honestly the people who
stake their assets on that node will get
a reward you know they're risking
something and they'll get a reward for
that node behaving accurately now that
sounds like a silly thing there are
large companies being established right
now that that's all they do is they they
take your asset and they figure out
where it's best to stake so that you get
the the best return and the safest
return on your funds that that's being
done at the institutional level so
that's
question representative
teria yeah thank you for taking a
question uh well the question is mostly
from my own understanding as I
understand that when you use the word
you know blockchain or uh digital asset
mining or Bitcoin mining yeah it
basically is running some algorithm
on super high computers high speed and
trying to you know use the algorithm
it's not really it's not really uh you
know physical mining or something so my
my the question is that and I couldn't
understand when you use the on page
three from line 22 to line 25 you're
talking about uh noise pollution or lot
of noise coming in that process can you
explain a little better like uh how when
you were talking about you
know algorithm and using supercomputers
to you know uh get it as fast as
possible where is the noise part coming
up that part I could understand yeah
that's a good question um
so so I'll take the home part first
right so it used to be you could mine
Bitcoin on a
laptop but there's something called the
difficulty adjustment where the more
computers crunch it the harder it gets
and the so there was an arms race in uh
Bitcoin where now to mine it you need a
special chip it's called an Asic it's a
specialized chip and all it does is as
efficiently as possible crunches the
Bitcoin mining algorithm and that's
probably outs we can buy one on on
online but it's a very small part of the
whole network but there are there are
other assets where you could still mine
it on a laptop um where the where the
noise comes from is a computer needs
energy to think right and one of the
byproducts is heat and so to dissipate
the heat so you don't burn up the chip
you need usually a fan and that's that's
generally the noisiest uh way to cool
you know if we're talking about a large
scale mining operation but there's
improvements on that even where there's
liquid cooling so they have liquid uh
flows over the you know some fins and
dissipates the Heat and that's much
quieter and that's where a lot of the M
the big mining operations are going okay
so okay so my understand so usually
usually the computers they always have
fan technology I know about that to pull
it off just like your computer at home
and need's a fan yeah so here you're
saying it requires a big fan or big
something that to cool it off and that
that is the noise that's where most of
the noise comes from thank you in large
scale mining operations this bill would
not exempt them from from noise
ordinances they would still have to
comply what it does is it prevents noise
ordinances from being weaponized against
just that particular industry which we
see in some other states so
burrow thank you and thank you for
taking my question and I think we're all
trying to learn this stuff as quickly as
we can yeah so you're talking about a
bad actor I think on the Node is it so
how how do you determine that somebody's
a bad actor and and who makes that
decision and to distribute those assets
so so instead of thinking in terms of
like a company where you have like
people in charge and making decisions
you have to think more in terms of a
protocol so a protocol is like your
email protocol or your HTTP protocol
right um it's a standard language that
people have to use in order to
communicate together that's what a
protocol basically is so the protocol of
the of the network and it it varies
depending on what network you're talking
about enforces the rules
and makes it easy for it's basically the
majority of the nodes would say that is
not an accurate block right they would
they would say according to the rules
that we're all playing by that looks
suspicious and they'll reject it and
then that would punish that node for not
complying with the rules right so
instead of you know let's say you send
me a couple tokens and the bad node
intervenes and says it gives your tokens
to somebody else right that would be
like a simple example of bad acting
right so the network would punish that
node and that's where the slash would
happen of the stake so it's like a it's
all risk and reward and
incentives yeah follow up you may
inquire again so again I'm so everybody
has these pass Keys how can you get in
to block that you understand what I'm
saying if you you know so when you when
are you talking about the slashing
events yeah so once your your
transaction gets
let's say I send you something I push a
button on my phone that transaction gets
broadcast to it's a pool of waiting
transactions so there's like a let's say
a bucket these are all the transactions
that haven't been written to the
blockchain yet and what the miners are
doing is taking those transactions and
minting a block and saying like this is
the permanent history of the blockchain
and so um so it's after you exercise
your control over the over the asset but
before it goes on to the blockchain
that's where someone can intervene in a
mic I'm probably not the only one here
but there's a lot of different uh
professions and uh education
legal etc etc etc that all all
are if you're going to be successful
have to have a role a role that we're
used to using all right so
um for example um when you say what is
the
asset and I'm going that's a good
question what the hell is the asset yeah
uh it's a digital something MH all right
it's not an animal it's not a dollar
it's not it's an asset so that that
throws me right off so the whole the the
underlying Innovation behind blockchain
is digital scarcity we have never had
digital scarcity before it's it's a
computer science problem that has been
solved
once was never solved before so what
digital scarcity means is you can create
a digital token just think of a big
number that you know that no one else
has and you can make it so that when I
give it to you I no longer possess it
right if I take a a Word document or a
picture and I and I attach it to an
email and I send it to you I still have
the word document I still have the
picture now there's two of them right so
digital assets up until blockchain was
invented were
infinitely uh replicatable duplicatable
and so the Innovation behind blockchain
is it it turns a digital asset into
something that can be possessed and and
transferred and no longer possessed you
see what I mean that's really the the
the the fundamental Innovation under all
of this okay I would I I would like to
see a professional come in and I'm not
saying you're not professional okay I'm
I'm I would I would like to see somebody
kind of connect the dots yeah not only
in terms of what a digital asset is
whether it's a service or a product
where's its value okay where's it proof
of value I guess is or yeah and and and
also uh when and I want to know uh how
you're going to regulate it you you you
you say you're the way I'm listening to
you is it's self-regulated there's a bad
guy somebody can come in and try and do
something but you've got it this mayy
tied up so tight uh that's not going to
ever uh cause a problem which I'm not
convinced that that's yeah well possible
like any technology it can be abused
right there there's no sure I'd like to
know where the weak points are and and
the uh uh uh policy
making is if you're going to be in the
public sector you're going to have to
have some po public policym in other
words you just can't go back in the and
get your your this fine product and come
out and
say trust me now I'm gonna it's always
going to work and I want a I want a
third party that that's associated with
the government mhm uh who who can put an
their imprimer on it yeah and I I can be
uh satisfied with that well respectfully
representative Herbert I don't expect
you to vote for this bill ever
so and that's okay we cane we disagree
you know no no I I just I'm I have a a
way of looking at the world and this is
a very new product to me and and I and
what's the trust I mean what I know what
a trust is in some other areas is are
they the same rules on on on this partic
particular product so I'm I'm running
into a problem of trying to
fix where you are in in the entire realm
of uh our our government and our money Y
and all those things and I'm I'm not
even close to being satisfied so I would
like to see profession
uh non uh not neutral individuals who
can explain to
me uh where the strengths are where the
weaknesses are make recommendations
where the politics should be all of
those things should be coming not from
you but from third parties that I would
I would
trust you know because I can't I you
know too much it's like what I know
about you know stocks and bonds and
Assets in my world I know but now a
digital asset comes along and I'm going
who was that you know I and it's hard
it's hard to for me to make a vote in my
in on behalf of my constituency and be
certain that I'm making a a good
decision I would believe that
representative Herbert thank
you okay I think everyone's a chance to
ask a question and remember with this is
going to subcommittee so please save
your questions for the representative in
the subcommittee all right thank you I
turn your mic on there you go all
right um my name is Patrick dero I'm a
resident of P New Hampshire I also a tax
practitioner that's located out of
hener
better there we go okay my name is
Patrick Deo I am uh tax practitioner
that's located out of hener New
Hampshire I also reside in
pemr uh I support the
bill mostly because of the definitions
that are outlaid in it uh considering
there's so much Ambu in the terminology
that's used in this space I've been
working in the digital asset space for
about 15 years uh with Emerging Markets
both overseas and located in other
states and a major hindrance has been
the ambiguity both in the judicial and
the financial spaces within the various
states of our our country and so the
hope is to unify the understanding uh
between all the verbiage that's being
used but also to set up which I you know
appreciate in here uh a judicial system
that can arbitrate things
correctly so I don't know if I need to
that's kind of all I really wanted to
say I don't know if I needed five
minutes or not
but I'm happy to answer your questions
so okay thank you very much
hayatt Mr chair and members of the
committee Ian hwit appearing in a
volunteer capacity as a board member of
the New Hampshire blockchain Council
what I'm hoping to do is just go step by
step through the issues that were raised
in the fiscal note not uh until you all
tell me to stop and then if possible I
would love to take any
questions so and I in particular what I
want to hit on are uh what the fiscal
note says about Securities Law what it
says about the potential blockchain
dispute docket and then contract and
Trust law so first to begin with the uh
Securities issue I I thought it was
notable that the fiscal note here uh
says that the Department of State the
Bureau of security ities will lose the
ability to regulate Mining and staking
it will no longer be able to regulate
those as Securities that's how the
Bureau of Securities phrased that change
but Mining and staking are not
Securities under regular established
federal or state Securities Law they
don't meet really any elements of the
legal test for what a security is except
that they can generate a profit for you
and you know when I read the end of that
paragraph I was struck by the fact that
the uh Bureau of security says pretty
specifically and confidently they
anticipate lost profits from not being
able to go after people doing and M
Mining and staking for um Securities
violations and what that suggests to me
is it almost seems like the Bureau of
Securities would like to adopt a kind of
Novel legal Theory to go after people
doing Mining and staking there's there's
certainly no applicable case law here in
in New Hampshire or in New England that
would suggest that mining or staking
could be a form of security so I thought
that point actually really underscored
the recommendation in the governor's
commission that when you have a new
technology people don't fully understand
the uncertainty around that can allow
for novel regulation by enforcement that
can deter Innovation and development so
I think that underscores the
recommendation of the commission to
encourage development and innovation in
this area in New Hampshire by creating
more clarity and stability around in
this case what is and is not a Security
even though this is really just a
codification of our regular uh State
statutory and other Securities tests
that we would apply in New Hampshire the
uh proposed blockchain dispute docket
these Provisions are just modeled pretty
directly on the existing RSA creating
our business dispute dispute docket
which I'm sure many of you are familiar
with um but in case you're not I thought
it'd be worth pointing out that this
350k cost cost that um is warned about
here by the Judiciary in the fiscal note
even if uh this bill were to pass and
then governor aot and the executive
Council were very proactive and
entrepreneurial and said we want to set
this dispute docket up right away and
Implement uh Governor shu's commission's
recommendations even then that 350k
expense would not be incurred by the
state until there was a lot of
profitable business in this area
happening in New Hampshire
and the reason for that is if you look
at the way the just regular business
dispute docket works now which is the
same system the presiding judge of that
docket is Judge David Anderson and he
does have an active uh business dispute
docket and I'm sure many of you have had
interactions with it but he also does
just all kinds of other regular Superior
Court cases when he's not doing uh
business docket cases so what would
happen if uh governor aod and the
council created this blockchain docket
right away
is an existing judge would be assigned
to it a judge with specialization in law
and technology and then the docket would
mostly just sit there while the judge
continued to do their other work but
hopefully in the meantime people doing
blockchain related business especially
in other states in New England would see
New Hampshire has this specialization
expertise and stability in blockchain
related business let's move there and
then that would increase the amount of
business happening on the blockchain
dispute docket and then finally the the
contract law and the trust law uh this
came up earlier but smart contracts and
common law contracts are really totally
different things and this is actually an
area where you know oftentimes uh
lawyers like me will will make really
kind of uninformed statements about
blockchain technology around smart
contracts sometimes the technologists
make really uninformed statements about
the law because they can even assume
smart contracts are a form of legal
contract and that's just not the case um
you know a smart contract for example
can keep operating and doing exactly
what it it was intended to do when let's
say all the parties are are dead so
there's there's no two parties there who
have any kind of offer acceptance
consideration and the smart contract is
is still running just to give an example
so it's it's orthogonal it's a separate
thing and representative Ammon does
clarify in the definition section here
that smart contracts and legal contracts
are really are really different things
although one could be used to facilitate
the other um there's a note here in the
fiscal note that no court is given
exclusive jurisdiction over trusts
operated through a smart contract and
the purpose of the provisions in this
bill are not to give any Court exclusive
jurisdiction or take any Court's
Jurisdiction away but just to provide
Clarity around what the legal principles
are that would apply to someone who in
New Hampshire tried to use a Smart
contract to to facilitate a self-settled
asset protection trust under under
current New Hampshire asset protection
trust law and then at the end there's
the statement that well there's some
ambiguities here and those ambiguities
uh I think the Bureau of security
suggested could create additional
litigation and additional expenses and I
would say on the contrary if if an
attorney uh for example never has any
intention of dealing with smart
contracts in their practice there any
RSA that speaks about smart contracts
that attorney is probably going to look
at it and not really understand what
it's talking about and I think that's
probably just unavoidable you can't you
know provide all the background
necessary to explain that concept to the
attorney in the RSA but I think any
practitioner who deals with law and
blockchain technology or any business
person who deals with blockchain related
technology would look at these rsas and
it would provide additional Clarity and
stability that would speak to exactly
the sorts of confusion uh that are
gestured at by some of the fiscal note
here and last last Quick couple of
sentences here I I see representative uh
spear I believe it was left but I just
wanted to speak to the energy um and
environmental concerns that she raised
and I wanted to draw your attention to
one aspect of this bill that is pretty
unique to New Hampshire is page 3 um 34
and 36 there's a special provision
clarifying that subdivisions can offer
positive incentives to encourage
blockchain related businesses to favor
proof of stake validation over proof of
work and that is in here for purely
environmental and energy use reasons
because some political subdivisions may
want to steer people towards this more
energy efficient uh method of validation
and the the intention there was not to
deter those subdivisions from trying to
promote environmentally friendly
practices in blockchain business and uh
questions representative Gibbs
thank
you and thank you for coming in to
testify this afternoon thank you um you
mentioned that um the uh expense to the
judicial system would only come if um
there were a lot of profitable
blockchain business but if there were a
lot of blockchain B business um and
therefore a lot of cases went to the
blockchain docket wouldn't it be true
that either
um the system would have to hire a new
judge at the expense of
$350,000 or um since uh one judge would
be taking all of that blockchain
business wouldn't all the other judges
have to uh take on a lot of extra work
and wouldn't that be a loss to the J
Judicial System either way well so
currently the way it works with the
business dispute docket and if if you
look at the business dispute docket rsas
you'll see representative Ammon has
basically just taken that exact text and
subbed in blockchain instead of uh
business which was the governor's
commission's recommendation for creating
this new dispute docket and what happens
there is uh pretty a lot of the cases I
think all of the cases on the business
dispute docket go to Judge David
Anderson currently uh who is the
presiding judge but he does not work
exclusively on the business dispute
docket so even there that's a pretty
active docket but we don't have enough
litigation there in the state to take
him away away totally from all the other
cases um and it's not as if we've
reassigned a judge just to the business
dispute docket so now all of the other
cases he would have handled are kind of
left to all of the other judges he he
works on both so the only situation in
which the Judiciary would hire a new
judge just to you know expend 350k just
handle all the blockchain business would
be after we've already established the
blockchain dispute docket it's been
around for a while it's probably been
mostly inac but now we've got all this
so much blockchain business in New
Hampshire and and litigation that the
Judiciary says we need a specialist
judge who works just on this stuff and
at that point potentially this 350k
incurred anyone
else okay thank you very much and seeing
as hell I have no more
cards we will close the hearing on HP
I'm waiting for I'm waiting for the
and I can't move I can't move forward
because the prime sponsor of 538 is the
same
and you're
bill what yeah $4.99 is your
bill according to the poop
sheet oh so yeah that's Insurance
is should
every a
dip I know I tried to figure out how
inp
back right but but but the one that's
most volatile
by is
crypto representative I have no pink
card
gos seven put them in dolls and I
just okay we'll open up the public
hearing on um House Bill 499 making
technical corrections to certain
insurance law and we'll invite up the
turn
commissioner who will explain to us and
me what's in this bill what the
technical Corrections are inspiring
start from the sponsor of the bill
exactly uh thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is DJ bonc Court I serve as the
commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department joining me at the
table is Emily dhy legal counsel for the
Property and Casualty unit within the
department I've got a whole host of
folks in the back should any of you need
their
wisdom the vast majority of House Bill
499 is ministerial we are trying to
clean up and clear up some of our
statutes we have done this I think this
is our third or fourth time bringing
forward a bill of this kind again just
trying to clean up the statutes bring
nomenclature up to present time clean up
some things that were not uh properly
tidied up as we passed other pieces of
legislation over the years but there are
obviously some highlights that I would
draw to your
attention so on page one you will see on
lines 12 through
18 so this particular provision came as
a result of an entirely unrelated matter
to Property and Casualty lines of
business which is what that particular
section speaks to
but it did help make us aware of the
fact there was something that needed to
be addressed there as well so the
incident that arose very briefly this
fall as many of you know because you
were likely either impacted yourselves
or you were hearing from constituents
was there was a large disruption in the
Medicare Advantage Market a lot of
companies were deciding to withdraw from
offering products in that market others
were dramatically changing their current
offerings and there was one carrier
foron reasons still not known to me that
decided that they were not going to
write business anymore in straford
County I don't know who in straford
County aggravated them but they weren't
writing in straford County anymore now
Medicare Advantage is not a product that
the insurance department regulates that
is overseen by the federal government
understandably the public is not
completely familiar with the products
that we do and do not regulate they hear
insurance they see insurance department
they came to us to get some assistance
and we were happy to do that there's a
little bit of a Nuance in the Medicare
space in the sense that we do not
oversee underlying Medicare we do not
oversee or regulate Medicare Advantage
we do oversee Medicare supplemental
plans and so in addition to us trying to
be good stewards of education and
guidance to the public there was a
direct policy implication for the
Department because as a result of the
disruption in that market the the
federal government allowed people if
they so chose who had lost their
Medicare Advantage plan to switch over
to Medicare supplemental without
underwriting they had extended
guaranteed issue for those products as a
result of this disruption and so as
we're trying to field these calls as
we're trying to put helpful information
out to the public and to those impacted
it became unbelievably difficult I
termed it a bit of a fog of War to
understand what carrier was doing what
exactly some carriers had put out press
releases saying that they were
withdrawing entirely for those who did
that we obviously knew but we were
hearing from Agents and Brokers and
others that were saying I don't know
what's going on but the plan that I've
had before is going
away and as I said we didn't know what
each and every carrier was doing so
we've brought forward in a separate bill
a notification provision that says if
you're withdrawing from the market if
you are dramatically changing your
current offerings or if you're not going
to write in a county or counties you've
just got to notify the department so
that when people come to us we are able
to be in a position to explain to them
exactly what's
happening we took that exact same
principle and we have applied it to the
PNC lines of business my understanding
is that currently there is a requirement
on behalf of the agents to notify we are
extending that notification requirement
to the companies as well let me be very
clear I have taken the absolute lightest
touch I possibly could with this
notification requirement all it takes is
for the company to send me an email for
XY and Z reason we are no longer going
to be offering XY orz coverage that's it
I'm not asking for certified mail on
parchment paper delivered by a stor
using only red ink some states do that
we're not doing that I just want the
heads up so that when the calls come in
from consumers I know what's going on
and I in my department our best position
to be able to provide guidance to those
consumers yes doesn't this fly on the
face of network
adequacy when it comes to like health
insurance we would never let a health
insurance company do that but you're
saying you're going to let it okay with
the
supplementals so when we're talking
specifically about Medicare Advantage
how we had to do this is because we do
not regulate those products at all at
all we put but we do license the
companies that sell those products so
what we put the notification requirement
into was the area of the statute the
licensing statute where we basically say
as a condition of you getting your
license in addition to everything else
you're required to do you're also going
to agree to this notification provision
should you decide you're going to not
write that line any anymore or any of
the other things that I've described we
couldn't get into the substance because
you run into Federal preemption issues
it's not a product that we regulate the
only way we could get at that particular
issue within State Statute was to look
to the licensing right well I guess my
concern is that when it came to the
concept of network adequacy is that we
are we were fearful that insurance
company and actually it's the same one
who just pulled out of her supplemental
Market that same company was doing a uh
an inadequate job of providing having
providers in the North Country so now
what we're saying is Well gee we're
going to let even Property and Casualty
companies to pull out of the North
country and and have less less insurance
companies up there well unless I'm
mistaken we don't have Network adequacy
like requirements in the PNC world the
way we do with health insurance so if a
carrier chooses not to write in a
particular area they don't have
to and I would just point out there are
some states I won't mention who they are
but California that tried to do things
like that and the consequence of that
was that the carrier decided to pull out
of the state altogether completely yeah
and so that was one of a number of
different things that has caused
California's Insurance Market to be in a
very bad place right but we do run the
risk of with passing this that we could
have some coming going forward some
insurance company deciding that they
don't want to do well there's nothing to
prevent count no but there's nothing to
prevent them from doing that now all of
this provision does is say if you're
going to do that you've got to let us
know yep right that's fine it's a pure
notification requirement okay in any
event a little bit of cleanup language
there is it pertains to the Department's
work with Surplus lines company I don't
think Emily is there anything you want
to highlight with that
um this is just to um this provision um
just clarifies that for um policies that
are ridden on New Hampshire risk that
insurance companies need to use a New
Hampshire Insurance licensed
adjuster and then um and that would
include the Surplus lines companies um
so this is just a clarification that for
New Hampshire policies on New Hampshire
RIS that carriers including Surplus
lines carriers need to use a New
Hampshire licensed claim adjuster to
handle the
claims all right there are any questions
that Mr chairman looks like I got a
question yes representative mle yes uh
thank you um just a clarification um if
a insurance company says they're going
to pull out of the
state I don't believe that they can
cancel a policy in force what they're
really saying is we're we're not going
to we're not going to renew that policy
we're not going to take any more
business that's right thank you yep
that's what they
did all right very good so moving on and
again I'm skipping over a couple of
things that in my mind are purely
ministerial but if they trigger
something for you by all means just just
say which section of the bill you're
doing sure so I'm going to skip over to
page three
holy moly okay and I'm looking at lines
26 through
27 so as you know within our department
we have our financial regulation unit
that is the unit in charge of overseeing
the Financial Health the financial
viability of companies doing operation
in New Hampshire we're making sure that
they have adequate reserves we're making
sure they're in Good Financial Health
obvious reason being very difficult for
an insurance company to pay claims if
they're bankrupt one of the things that
we require when a company is looking to
form in New Hampshire and domesticate in
New Hampshire is that they have certain
assets certain dollars
upfront so that we know on day one
they're going to be in a decent
financial position to be able to start
begin offering and writing policies and
be able to cover any claims that come in
under those policies
the financial reg team has said that
because the provision currently says
that the dollar amount that is set for
the conversation to even begin which is
at
$800,000 is so low they are being
inundated with all sorts of interesting
characters with very interesting ideas
as to the types of insurance
companies that they would like to form
and domesticate here in New Hampshire
and in a lot of cases it's just not a
serious proposal and it takes up a lot
of time and
resources so I said what is the
appropriate amount to set there such
that we are weeding out the non-serious
actors from while also at the same time
ensuring that we are not setting the bar
so high that we are stifling new players
that want to enter the
market and my lovable math nerds came to
me and said $3 million is a serious
number that again is not doing anything
to stifle or drive away potentially
interested players who want to again
enter the New Hampshire Market in a very
serious way which is to say form and
then domesticate here so that's what is
reflected
there heading over to page four looking
at lines 8 through 14 and then really
extending over the course of the next
couple of pages
we are eliminating a number of
fees and I appreciate that like all of
you you see the revenue statements that
come in certain revenues are not doing
as well as hoped I completely understand
that I do not want to compound that
problem I had a great conversation
earlier this week with your colleagues
over at Ways and Means I think they're
pretty happy with me the insurance
premium tax is doing
well but there are some fees that our
licensing unit has come to us and said
look the cost that it takes to collect
these fees and to enforce compliance
with these fees way outstrips the actual
amount of Revenue that the state is
getting from this and I think that what
we're talking about here is reflected in
the fiscal note which is the totality of
the fees that we're talking about here
are in the range of 20 to
$330,000 and again the time and effort
having to chase people around some of
these fees make absolutely no sense you
know charging somebody a fee because
they're changing their name on their
license because they got
married I mean really I just think that
that's a a nuisance and an inconvenience
to the people who are doing good work in
the state we're preserving some of them
for sure but in statute it says that in
order for us to change the definition of
an amendment to a license we have to get
it changed in statute and thus why this
is coming before you if you're worried
about the 20 to
$30,000 um I'll get George russos to
take it out of his bonus
well well speak funny you mentioned
George because um the issue I always
thought was the
fees uh were to go after people who were
not uh going to be part of the
assessment now words only domestic are
getting
assessed and so therefore this this
these fees are way to make the pain for
being a domestic
less but if you're telling me it's so
little amount of money the domestics
don't care yeah it's little it's little
make no mistake I think producers across
the board are appreciative of the fact
that we're trying to inject a little bit
of customer friendly common sense into
into this process and not charge fees to
as I said in some cases really are
absurd and just entirely unnecessary and
again the staff time that goes into it
is a lot and our licensing unit in
particular as I think I've told you is
undertaking a number of very big
projects we're currently reoccuring the
vendor that the state that our
department has to administer the
licensing exam I don't need those guys
diverting time and attention away from
chasing people around for you know their
married name versus their maiden name
and and some of the other things that
we've identified as being something that
would be considered a formal amendment
to their license that would then trigger
them to have to pay the
fee so hopefully that kind of explains
that and I think other than that it's
just a bunch of changes to the numbering
within the statute to account for the
other small changes that have been made
here have I missed anything big Emily
who's way smarter than I am although
that's a low Bar says I haven't missed
anything
important all good any questions anybody
looks
good anybody else would like to testify
hearing
okay hey Mike would you tell the you are
you headed out the door you tell the
so for the new members of the committee
um departments often have these
technical Corrections and adjustments um
they ask me to sponsor the bill and I I
I don't testify because I don't really
have any skin in the game about what the
bills are about um and but that it's um
um that's why this hearing process is a
little different than most hearing
processes I I would say I would in e in
either case I would make sure that I not
going to have a hear any Guff about the
bill because then it would be that would
be problematic that I'm sponsoring the
bill and shairing the meeting but uh
these are these are departments bills
and when they run them by me they seem
very benign
so and a good thing to the state of New
Hampshire
good afternoon Mr
the no now we are thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee good afternoon
Joseph Mica chairman of the New
Hampshire liquer commission and with me
Tina deir our
CFO and to to your point Mr chairman
that's exactly what this is this is what
we call a housekeeping bill um if you
look on page two the organizational
structure of the Liquor Commission uh
Commission of Office of the commission
division of enforcement division of
administration and the division of
marketing and Merchandising that
division of administration is what we
called the COO position and we're taking
that position and we're um we're
attempting to uh make a division of
administration and a division of finance
this is a recommendation that was given
to Us by the LBA a few years ago in one
of our audits The Liquor Commission is
audited every year by the LBA and this
was something that we put on hold until
our new nextg system our new back of the
house and front of the house system was
put into place uh obviously uh you run a
business finance is the backbone of
every business and uh Tina's done a
wonderful job over the years Tina is a
30-year employee of the liquor commiss
Mission and she's done a wonderful job
as CFO running it down on page three
we'll look at the new uh outline of of
it which would have the office of the
commission the division of enforcement
and their full-time positions division
of administration their full-time
positions the division of finance and
the division of
marketing uh this will be covered within
our current operating budget no
additional funds will be necessary for
us to do this and it will have no impact
to our
budget and basically the POS the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission director of
the division of finance and auditing
will be responsible for the agency
oversight and efficiency of the finance
and auditing operations of the Liquor
Commission the position directs fiscal
operations with limited resources to for
the most productive uses and with the
AIM as always of optimizing revenue and
creating value for the citizens of New
Hampshire and the consumers that's
shopping our stores of which 50% come
from out of state so with that Mr
chairman I'd be happy to answer any
questions that anyone may have for
either for myself or Tina thank
you oh representative
spear this is probably a silly question
but what is unclassified versus
classified mean with respect to people
are they it's it's the um type of
position so the directors are
unclassified positions and then all of
the other employees are classified what
does the classified mean it's not
security I mean whether we can fire them
or not it's what at the working at the
will
of oh is that what that means it doesn't
maybe
ATF but yeah clarent is just basically
you know who who can get fired at at
will which
one which the unclassified positions are
of okay so that answered your question
okay representative
Kips thank you
um just for clarify a isn't classified
position similar to in the federal
government civil
service with the protection yes yes
thank you um okay my question is um
there's a reference to removing uh a
commissioner position from the list of
unclassified employees does that mean
getting rid of a position or changing it
from unclassified to classified or
something else uh representative that
position years ago the commission was
run by three Commissioners and one acted
as the chairman several years ago the
the legislature changed to one chairman
and a Deputy Commissioner and that
reference to a commissioner being the
third commissioner was something that
was just never taken out of the language
so that was just a housekeeping piece of
that
bill um followup question for the
uhif sorry um where it says two
unclassified and one classified which
would be a total of three in fact
there's a total of two one unclassified
and one unclassified no uh
representative the two unclassified
would be myself and the Deputy
Commissioner and the one classified
would be our Administrative Assistant
that we share
pleasure that's
it in the old
days just have to tell a story
right in the old days we we had three
Commissioners because they were really
the judges when it came to license
suspensions so that for years that was
the idea of having three Commissioners
and then but only one of them was the
chair
uh the other one was supposed to be in
charge of uh marketing and the third one
was in charge of
enforcement and uh and then once we
changed this the structure and got rid
of one one position uh she she retired
so it was a window of opportunity for us
to do away with the position and that's
how we have this the situation we have
now thank you very very much Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you I
always like to tell tell some history
tell the story the whole story we love
the uh did you guys fill out a pin
card
okay all
room we will close the public hearing at
5:38 okay so um having going through all
everything what in terms of next week it
turns out I can't get a room unless it's
a really small room um for Tuesday so um
we're unfortunately not going to meet
again
Tuesday we could be cozy but it's it's
room 104 which was my old uh my my
sabatical committee room when I um it's
a very cozy little room about the you
all want to come
to oh yeah you want that drive you
really want to come down there I think
so all right so what uh and because we
are going to have a session on
Thursday so that means we will meet um
next
Tuesday and I will pretty much excuse me
Wednesday sorry sorry sorry so that
means we'll meet next Wednesday and what
I will be doing is is is making a mop up
I think I think I've got all I think of
all the early bills have already been
scheduled we've already um we have we
hear them
tomorrow but that um I know we have one
more ambulance
bill okay and this this is the the uh
this is the one that's being put forward
by the the fire chiefs the one that's
got the
230% over Medicaid so um before we can
take action on the other two and we I
want to have all three heard so we will
hear that next next
Wednesday but then that forces that uh
because the ambulance bill needs to get
out the following Thursday I mean
Wednesday or Tuesday well but Wednesday
is for
sure um because I never know what
committee rooms I can get um so the
following Wednesday which is
the
day and which we will take up the
ambulance
bills that and and any other all the
early bills I want to I want to have do
all the subcommittees on any of the
early bills on that 12th so that means
then um the
19th um will be when we need to exec all
the bills that have to be out for March
6 because the following week is vacation
week that's another Wednesday we do have
because we do have a March 5th that if
if we don't get all the early bills done
and prior to the vacation we can still
out I guess I don't need this but when
when last we did the um uh ambulance
bills the way we left it if I remember
correctly was we were going to get the
uh the folks that did the analysis to
come in yes and the second piece
was the Chiefs gave Dr AIS
the backup for how they came up with
their numbers and he was going to do an
different so they and they said that
they're working on that and they should
have the answer for that within the next
you know they expected to present it
next week but it sounds like they some
of this stuff is going to get pushed out
right at this point um yeah we're we're
we're we're scheduling that not for next
week but for the the following week yeah
the 12 so we still going to be able to
hear from the folks who did the original
an actually the reason why is the the
consultant that the department uses out
of state so that's why I'm confirming
that 12th date I've just confirmed that
with person if you were wondering what I
was doing out in the
hallway that's what I was negotiating
that date that's good for the consultant
yes okay I'm a little unclear okay so
Wednesday the 12th Wednesday the 12th we
will have subcommittees it will be
Insurance the the high profile one will
be the
insurance subcommittee and which we will
definitely be taking up first thing is
the ambulance
bills and then the 19th you can execute
the 19th will
exec also a a Wednesday Wednesday
Wednesday okay
yeah so are we meeting next Thursday be
the next Thursday the 6th is a session
day
that's how we got on the short end of
the sick because they wanted us to meet
happen
morning at n they did but that was when
they had a big load we still
right well we will you know in terms of
this committee we will have our exec
session tomorrow and so those bills will
Thursday when do you expect we'll be
done with everything when
yeah uh well terms of all 36 bills that
are in our committee so um I I will then
will say is that pretty quickly we're
going to have done all our hearings yeah
so like I said the the the first D to
iogi was that was that we had uh that
Wednesday the 5th we've got to make sure
we've exec all the early bills which was
about 13 of them and then we'll have the
12th the 19 and we have two three weeks
that we can get rid of all the rest of
them in March in March 20th right so we
have two
weeks to toh get rid of you know to to
do subcommittees and exact everything
right so we're we're definitely it's a
little lighter than last year last year
was a little stressful at the end there
um but you know we don't have any of the
housing housing bills so that makes it a
lot
easier
e